[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and I'm
sorry I missed you last week.
We tried recording the
show from the airplane,
but they just weren't having it.
So here's your update
about the coolest developer
news from Google in
the last two weeks.
Time to do final testing
of your Android apps
for Android Nougat.
Developer preview
five is now available,
and it's the final one before
Nougat begins rolling out
to devices later this summer.
This preview gives you
near-final system updates
for all of the supported
preview devices.
Find the post linked below
for more details, including
how to get the preview.
An update to the Android
Wear 2.0 developer preview
is now available with wearable
drawers' enhancements, wrist
gestures, and more.
Getting started details
are on the post.
Like most kids' app
developers, Story Toys
had the challenge of engaging
with the right audience.
Since the launch of the
family section on Google Play,
Story Toys has experienced
an uplift of 270% in revenue
and an increase of
1,300% in downloads.
Take a look at the video
linked below for more.
Showcase your game at the
Google Play Indie Games Festival
in San Francisco
on September 24.
We're accepting submissions
through August 14
for this opportunity to show
your title to the public
and compete to win
great prizes, including
tickets for Google I/O 2017
and Google Ad campaign support.
The marker clustering you're
familiar with on the Google
Maps SDK for Android
and JavaScript
is now available on iOS as well.
Don't miss out on your analytics
while your progressive web
app is offline.
Check out this post and grab
the NPM package for everything
you need to handle offline
Google Analytics requests
within your service worker.
The latest mobile ads garage
covers AdMob's Native Ads
Express is now on YouTube.
Get more powerful bid
automation with Smart Bidding,
our conversion-based automated
bidding across AdWords
and DoubleClick search
backed by machine learning.
Examples and links
are on the post.
Stackdriver error
reporting is now
generally available on
the Google App Engine
standard environment.
No setup is required.
It just works out of the box
for Java, Python, Go, and PHP
applications.
Two machine learning APIs that
are part of the Google Cloud
platform are now
entering open beta.
The Google Cloud
natural language API
lets you easily reveal
the structure and meaning
of your text in a
variety of languages,
and the Cloud Speech API allows
speech-to-text conversion
in over 80 languages.
Head over to the blog post
for more details and links.
As always, check
out the description
below for all the links.
Don't forget to
subscribe and send us
your questions with the
hashtag #AskDevShow.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]